Susi's weather Susie's in California hi
Suzie how are you hi Dave it's great to
talk to you you're taking my call sure
so I have $400,000 in a money market
account and I would like to help my kids
get out of their debt because I'm kind
of wrapped into it with them my oldest
daughter and her husband
we bought property with two houses on it
and we owe 380,000 and I kind of like to
pay that off and then you know I was
happy just to do that and not have them
pay me back but they said the only way
they'd agree to do it is if I would let
them pay half of it back to me so how
old are you I'm 61 are you living in one
of the houses I am yes and they're
living in the other one that's correct
on 10 acres okay cool and how many other
children do you have I have another
daughter who I am a cosigner on her
student loan for eighteen thousand five
hundred and I would like to pay that off
and have her pay me back at a lower
interest I would never put someone that
I love in debt to me so no I'm not
I would not have her bring you back I
would either right I would either leave
her alone or I'd write a check and pay
off the eighteen thousand that's real
easy I probably just pay off the
eighteen thousand because it's a debt
you've got to you're the cosigner on it
and I'd probably just remove that check
as far as the as far as the farm deal
goes it's not fair to the other daughter
if your estate is diminished by $400,000
oh the second daughter yeah yeah what do
you mean how does she get her share of
the estate when it's tied up in
farm that has to prop two houses on it
one of which she has no desire to live
in well I have a million dollars in a
portfolio that if you know something
happened to me it goes to both of them
so be easy enough to be easy enough for
the child with the farm to take their a
portion of their portion as the farm and
you're just advancing you're just
advancing them you're in Heather your
inheritance right right and actually
that's written in the trust that they
have they have the first I don't know
what it's called but they they can pay
it off with their amount and then it
goes into what's left over that date
they devoxx exactly you can do that and
that that's the way they don't need to
pay you back so that you can give it to
them again when you die I know we see
that okay you know well you're gonna get
the money when I die anyway and so all
I'm doing is giving it to you before I
die yeah that's the reality so yeah if
you since you've got you you've done
very well and you have a really nice net
worth and you got a lot of liquidity so
we've got the daughter with the student
loan taking care we write that check
she's done and she's gonna get her half
out of that million the kids are gonna
get their half partially out of the
million and other kids and partially out
of the the farm that you paid off in
advance and so what you do is you reduce
the kids that are on the farm you reduce
what they're going to receive as an
inheritance by the amount that you used
to pay this off and you don't worry
about gift tax because you're one of the
owners of the farm so you can pay off
your own farm anytime you want there's
no gift tax issue on this estate but you
do want to say the four hundred thousand
or the two hundred thousand or whatever
it works out to be the proper amount of
their inheritance is reduced by that and
they got they just got it before you
died that's all and no I don't want to
put either one of them in debt to you
know I don't want an interest rate no I
don't
payments from either one of them to you
you've got plenty of money you're gonna
be sitting there on a debt-free property
next door to your kids life is good and
and you've still got a million dollars
plus in other assets so you're in fine
shape that's exactly what I did right
check pay off all these debts and no I
wouldn't let any of them repay you know
it's you just it just becomes a dog
chasing its tail and you don't want to
have payments going back and forth and a
family it just creates all kinds of
problems